some of the nation's top intelligence
officials were forced to defend their
agencies today during that congressional
testimony we just referenced it was
supposed to be a day for the worldwide
threat assessment but chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge reports
there were almost as many issues about
threats from within as from the outside
many many many many times a day I'm
confronted with unbelievable examples of
integrity and professionalism and grit a
forceful defense of the FBI from
director Christopher Rea who was asked
about president Trump's characterization
of rays bureau do you think the FBI's
reputation is in any way in tatters and
are you confident in the independence of
your agents I'm a big believer in the
idea that the FBI speaks through its
work through its cases through the
victims it protects the annual
intelligence threat hearing often
dominated by terrorism got into the rush
investigation and the political fallout
on the House Republican staff memo that
alleges surveillance abuses by the FBI
in Justice Department during the 2016
election we had then and continue to
have now grave concerns about the
accuracy of the memorandum because of
omissions we provided thousands of
documents that were very sensitive and
lots and lots of briefings and it's very
hard for anybody to distill all that
down to three and a half pages but there
were no hard questions for the panel on
the Democrats counter memo that needs
heavy redactions before the White House
says the president will declassify it on
Russia's 2016 election interference the
nation's intelligence chief said there
is universal agreement there should be
no doubt that Russia perceived that its
past efforts as as successful and views
the 2018 u.s. midterm elections as a
potential target for Russian influence
operations while Russian President
Vladimir Putin's government is laying
the groundwork to disrupt the midterms
raised said they're already working with
homeland security at the FBI together
with DHS recently for example scheduled
meetings with various election state
election officials there are ways if
people are a little bit creative and
forward leaning to educate the state
election the American people are smart
people there
they realized that there's people
attempting to manipulate them both
domestically in foreign with no clear
punishment for Russia one senator called
for greater involvement from the top I
just wish you all could persuade the
president as a matter of national
security to separate these two issues
the collusion issue is over here
unresolved we cannot confront this
threat which is a serious one with a
whole-of-government response when the
leader of the government continues to
deny that it exists during the three and
a half hour session other headlines
unfolded on North Korea Kim jong-un is
not hearing the full story that is that
those around him aren't providing nuance
aren't suggesting to him the tenuous
nature of his position both
internationally and domestically on
China I'm not sure in the two hundred
and forty some odd year history of this
nation we've ever faced a competitor and
potential adversary of this scale scope
and capacity on the national debt the
nation's intelligence chief testified
it's unsustainable and poses a national
security threat adding the assessment is
shared by current and former
intelligence officials from both parties
brett catherine herridge on capitol hill
catherine thank you